for years since the earthquake and  tsunami which caused such catastrophic  damage this is the first view inside one  of the reactors at Fukushima the  specifically designed transformer robot  was sent inside reactor number one to  take these images to record the  temperature and crucially the radiation  levels at the bottom right of the  picture the radiation level is measured  in sieverts per hour  it varies as the robot moves through the  reactor at these levels a human would  survive for a matter of minutes most  electronic devices would fail too and  even this one specially designed failed  after just three hours but it was enough  to get important new information